Throughout history and across all
cultures, whether it's a tribal ritual
the two-step or "twerking" we all have a
personal way of expressing ourselves on
the dance floor, or at home in front of
the mirror. And well some of us are seemingly a
lot better than others, the question
remains; are these expressions actually
individual or part of an imbedded human code? Why are we so drawn to dance and
it it really equivalent to a human meeting
call?  More importantly does dancing
increase your potential to "get some"?
From a viewers perspective dance can be
pleasurable to watch for many of the
same reasons music is enjoyable to
listen to. But it was the science legend
Charles Darwin who first suggested that
dance could be part of mating rituals and entangled
with the evolution and survival
of our species.
But if this is true the ability to dance
must somehow relate to the ability to
survive and reproduce,
so does it?
It turns out that early humans who were
co-ordinated, symmetrical and rhythmic
were seen as more viable to a mate
because these traits were often linked to
survival.  The ability to run faster,
defend against prey and ultimately survive.
And dancing just happens to be an
outward manifestation and display of
many of these qualities.  A quick external
way of documenting and proving your
fitness in order to attract to mate.  This
desire to dance can even be seen in
babies as early as five months old bopping
to a beat, in fact many species use
dance or movement to swoon the opposite
sex.
From spiders to a variety of birds
and even bees which use dance moves to
communicate entire messages.
But why are humans compelled to dance to
music?  It likely has something to do with
the fact that many of the brains reward systems are directly connected to
the motor areas.  For example, music
stimulates the cerebellum at the base of
the brain which is involved in the timing
and coordination of movement.
In a contemporary sense, dance is known
to show confidence and fearlessness, and
sometimes intoxication.  But most
importantly, movements associated with
good dancing are indicative of good
health and reproductive potential.
And in many cases, the human courtship
ritual in our natural habitat of a
nightclub mirrors that of animals in the
wild.  This gives
"being an animal on the dance-floor" a
new meaning, except are liquid courage
doesn't come from the local water hole.
Ironically many men feel as though they
can't dance or that dancing isn't for
them.  But in most animals the males must
impress the female.  So what is a good
dancing then?  Scientists have actually studied
which male dance movements were most
attractive to women.  Interestingly, it was
seen that twisting, bending and fluid
movements of the core body region (like
the torso neck and head) garnered the
most positive attention from women.
Showing variability, flexibility and
creativity
was perceived as good dancing.  On the
other hand, repetitive rigid and twitchy
movements were not particularly attractive.
Sometimes called "dad dancing".  And
truthfully, your dad probably dances a
little slower and more rigid than his
youthful counterpart because, simply put,
he isn't as youthful or fit anymore.
So whether you're in a club, a bar, you're own living room, engage and embrace your
animal instincts.  And if you are asked where you got those moves, just say millions of years of
evolution have led to this dance baby.
Who knew science could be so groovy?
This episode of a AsapSCIENCE is supported
by audible.com, the leading
provider of audiobooks with over 100 000 downloadable titles
across all types of literature.
If you would like to learn more about
evolution, I recommend the book "The
Greatest Show on Earth" by Richard
Dawkins.  You can download this audio book
or another of your choice for free at
audible.com/asap. Special thanks
to audible for making these videos possible
and offering you a free audio book
at audible.com/asap
and subscribe from our weekly science
videos.